PROFESSOR: Hi there.
Welcome back to recitation.
In lecture, you've been learning
about when vectors are linearly
independent, when they span
the space, what a basis is,
what a dimension of
a vector space is.
And the problem for today
is exactly about that.
We have a vector
space that is given.
It's spanned by
these four vectors.
And we're asked to find the
dimension of that vector space
and the basis for it.
Well, why don't you hit pause
on the video, and work on it
for a while.
And I'll come back in a little
bit to help you out with it.
We're back.
Let's work on it.
So we need to find the
dimension and the basis.
Remember what the dimension is?
It's simply the
number of vectors
in a basis for the vector space.
So actually, the
problem is backwards.
We want to find the
basis for the space
first, and then
find the dimension.
I'll write "first"
here and "second" here.
So we want to find a basis
for the vector space spanned
by these four vectors.
So you might be
tempted to just say
that a basis for
this vector space
is those four vectors, because
they span the vector space.
But there's another thing
that a basis has to satisfy.
And it is the elements
of the basis have
to be linearly independent.
We don't know that these are.
So we have to check.
How do we check
that four vectors
are linearly independent?
Well, there's a couple
of different ways.
But here's what
we're going to do.
We're going to put these
vectors as rows of a matrix.
And then we'll do elimination.
And when we get to the end,
the rows that have pivots
are the independent ones.
So let's do that.
1, 1, -2, 0, -1; 1, 2, 0, -4, 1;
0, 1, 3, -3, 2; 2, 3, 0, -2, 0.
By now you must have done
elimination a million times,
so I'll go a little bit faster.
1, 1, -2, 0, -1; 0,
1, 0, +2, -4, 2--
this one's already done-- 1,
3, -3, 2; 2 minus 2, 3 minus 2,
0 plus 4, -2, and 2.
One more step.
1, 1, -2, 0, -1-- all these
are done-- 0, 1, 2, -4, 2; 0,
1 minus 1 is 0, 3 minus 2 is 1,
-3 plus 4 is 1, 2 minus 2 is 0,
1 minus 1 is 0,
2, 2 again, and 0.
Well, you can see
where this is going.
In the next step, this
row is going to disappear.
1, 1, -2, 0 -1; 0, 1, 2, -4, 2;
0, 0, 1, 1, 0; 0, 0, 0, 0, 0.
All right.
We're done with elimination.
So let's circle our pivots.
All right, here are our pivots.
We have three pivots.
And so these three rows
are linearly independent.
And in fact, these rows
still span the same space
that the initial four rows did.
Because when you do elimination,
all that you're doing
is recombining
your rows by doing
linear combinations of them.
So, for example, your first
row stayed the same throughout.
Your second row was replaced
by row 2 minus row 1.
But it's really still
spanning the same space.
And it goes on.
And then the fourth row,
it turns out, was useless.
You only needed the first three.
So the elements for a basis--
well, it will be these three.
So let me write that.
Basis [1, 1, -2, 0, -1],
2, 2, and [0, 0, 1, 1, 0].
Could you have used
the first three rows?
Yes, you could.
You can't always do that.
Sometimes in elimination,
you have to switch rows,
because there's a 0
where a pivot should be.
When that happens, you
have to use these three,
or you have to keep
track of which row
you switched to go back
and use the initial ones.
But it's really safe
to use these ones.
And also they're simpler than
the ones that you started with,
so why not?
The other question
that we had was:
what is the dimension
of the vector space?
Well, this is the easy part.
The dimension of the
vector space is 1, 2, 3.
And that solves the problem.
But there's one more thing
that I want to tell you.
I told you that there's
a couple of ways
to find out which of
those four vectors
are linearly independent.
And the one that I used
was I put them into rows
and performed elimination
and picked out the rows
that have pivots on them.
Another way to do it is to
write the initial vectors
as columns of the matrix and
then perform elimination.
That also works
and, as you know,
because you're only working with
the transpose of this matrix,
you get the same
number of pivots.
Let's go over here where I have
the same-- well, the transpose
of that matrix-- I
have the same vectors,
but now written as columns.
My four initial vectors
written as columns.
And here I have
performed elimination.
And this is the final result.
Let me circle the pivots again.
Here they are,
three, which is going
to give me three linearly
independent vectors
and hence, three elements
of the basis, and hence,
dimension 3 for
the vector space.
But I could no longer
use these three columns
as elements of the basis,
because when I did elimination,
I changed the column space.
So the column space
of this matrix
is not the same as
the column space
of the eliminated version.
So I cannot use these.
In fact, if you
look at them, you
can probably understand
that they're not
going to span the
same space as these.
Because all that I
have down here are 0's,
and I get a lot more than
just 0's in the last two
entries of the vectors.
So what I need to
do is-- the pivots
are in the first, second,
and third columns.
I need to use these three
columns as my basis.
I'll just write basis down here.
And that will work too.
So see, I have produced
two different bases
for the same vector space,
which is totally fine.
You can pick the
basis that you prefer.
All right.
We're done.
Thank you.